>> Sean: A BREAKING NEWS
"HANNITY EXCLUSIVE."
WE HAVE OBTAINED BODY CAM
FOOTAGE OF RAPHAEL WARNOCK'S
DISPUTE WITH HIS WIFE WHERE SHE
ACCUSED HIM OF TRYING TO RUN HER
OVER WITH HIS CAR.
HE RAN OVER HER FOOT WITH HIS
CAR AND WHERE HIS CRYING EX-WIFE
TOLD POLICE THAT WARNOCK IS A
GREAT ACTOR AND HE HAD DONE ALL
THIS AND SUGGESTED THAT HE HAS A
VIOLENT PAST.
WE'LL PLAY THE TAPE, LET YOU
DECIDE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> AND HE JUST STARTS BACKING
THE CAR UP.
I'M NOT BLEEDING BUT I CAN'T
BELIEVE HE WOULD RUN ME OVER.
>> SO YOU THINK IT WAS
INTENTIONAL?
>> I DON'T THINK HE CARES.
OBVIOUSLY I WAS STANDING HERE,
THE DOOR IS OPEN.
I'M LEANING IN TO THE CAR.
HOW CAN YOU DRIVE THE CAR WHEN
I'M LEANING INTO IT?
HE KNEW IT'S A RISK.
HE DOESN'T CARE.
HE CARES ABOUT HIMSELF.
HE HAS A FLIGHT TO CATCH.
THAT'S ALL THAT MATTERS.
THIS MAN IS RUNNING FOR THE
UNITED STATES SENATE AND ALL HE
CARES ABOUT IS HIS REPUTATION.
I TRIED TO KEEP THE WAY HE ACTS
UNDER WRAPS A LONG TIME.
I'VE HAD ENOUGH OF HIM THINKING
HE CAN DO WHATEVER HE WANTS AND
TREAT ME WHATEVER WAY.
I CAN'T BE QUIET FOR HIM
ANYMORE.
I'VE HAD IT.
>> Sean: SHE'S MAKING AN
ACCUSATION THAT HE WAS USING HIS
CAR AS A WEAPON TO RUN HER OVER.
HE RAN OVER HER FOOT IN THE
PROCESS AS A RESULT OF THIS
DOMESTIC DISPUTE.
RAISES A QUESTION, WHY WASN'T
RAPHAEL WARNOCK ARRESTED AND
CHARGED IN THE INCIDENT, WHICH
DOES IN ITSELF RAISE A LOT OF
ETHICAL QUESTIONS?
ISN'T IT STANDARD OPERATING
PROCEDURE FOR A POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND ALL AROUND THE
COUNTRY WHEN THERE'S A DOMESTIC
DISPUTE AND THERE IS AN
ALLEGATION OF VIOLENCE THAT ONE
PERSON IS TAKEN DOWN TO POLICE
HEADQUARTERS, THE ONE THAT IS
CHARGED?
WARNOCK'S TROUBLES DON'T STOP
THERE.
HE WANTS TO END CASH BAIL,
DEMONIZES POLICE AND REFERS TO
THEM AS THUGS AND GANGSTERS.
HE SAID YOU CANNOT SERVE GOD AND
THE MILITARY.
HE COMPARED AMERICA'S LEGACY TO
FIDEL CASTRO.
HE PRAISED LUIS FARRAKHAN AND
THE REVEREND JEREMIAH WRIGHT.
HE WANTS CRT IN SCHOOLS.
HE SUPPORTS ABORTION ON DEMAND
THROUGH THE NINTH MONTH.
NO RESTRICTION ON ABORTION.
HE'S BEEN A RUBBER STAMP FOR
BIDEN AND THE GREEN NEW DEAL
ALARMISTS.
HE'S HELL BENT ON DESTROYING OUR
WAY OF LIFE IN THIS COUNTRY.
WARNOCK IS ONE OF MANY EXTREME
SOCIALISTS RUNNING FOR OFFICE.
THAT INCLUDES THE EVER
STRUGGLING SOCIALIST TO THE LEFT
OF BERNIE SANDERS, TRUST FUND
BRAT IN A HOOD DID THAT NEVER
WORKED A JOB IN HIS LIFE.
JOHN FETTERMAN.
AN NBC REPORTER NOTED THAT
FETTERMAN STRUGGLED TO SPEAK,
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THE
CONVERSATION PRIOR TO THE
INTERVIEW.
OF COURSE, THAT REPORTER FACED
PUSH BACK FROM SAVANNAH GUTHRIE.
>> NBC AGREED TO USE A
TRANSCRIPTION PROGRAM DURING
THIS INTERVIEW BECAUSE HE'S
EXPERIENCING AUDITORY PROCESSING
ISSUES FROM THE STROKE.
MEANING HE CAN'T ALWAYS
UNDERSTAND WHAT HE'S HEARING.
>> WALK ME THROUGH THE CLOSED
CAPTIONING AND HOW IT WORKS.
>> IT'S HOW THINGS HAPPEN.
BECAUSE I SOMETIMES WILL HEAR
THINGS IN A WAY THAT IS NOT
PERFECTLY CLEAR.
I USE CAPTIONING.
I'M ABLE TO SEE WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IN CAPTIONING.
>> SAVANNAH, WE FOUND THAT IN
SMALL TALK BEFORE THE INTERVIEW
WITHOUT CAPTIONING, IT SEEMED IT
WAS DIFFICULT FOR FETTERMAN TO
UNDERSTAND OUR CONVERSATION.
>> YOU MENTIONED THAT LAST NIGHT
ON NIGHTLY.
SINCE THEN, OTHER JOURNALISTS
THAT DEALT WITH FETTERMAN SAID
THEY HAD A DIFFERENT EXPERIENCE.
>> YEAH, SAVANNAH, THAT IS
COMPLETELY FAIR THAT THAT WAS
THEIR EXPERIENCE.
WE CAN ONLY REPORT OUR OWN.
>> Sean: MAYBE SOMEBODY COULD
SHOW THE TAPE OF FETTERMAN
SAYING KICK THE BALLS IN
AUTHORITY AND MAYBE CALLING JOE
BIDEN JOE BIN.
DURING AN INTERVIEW TODAY WITH
THE PENN LIVE EDITORIAL BOARD,
BOARD MEMBER JEFFERY LORD, A
FRIEND OF THIS PROGRAM ASKED
FETTERMAN ABOUT MY OPEN
INVITATION FOR HIM TO JOIN THE
PROGRAM AND TOP DO MY RADIO
SHOW, IF HE WANTS FORKS THE FULL
THREE HOURS.
HERE'S THE RESPONSE.
>> SEAN HANNITY SAID THAT HE'S
REPEATEDLY ISSUED AN INVITATION
TO YOUR CAMPAIGN TO GO HIS GUEST
SOLO FOR THREE HOURS OF THE RAY
SHOW AND ONE FULL HOUR OF HIS
NATIONAL TV SHOW.
HE SAID HE'S GOTTEN NO RESPONSE
FROM YOU WHICH I ASSUME MEANS
YOU'RE A NO.
SO MY QUESTION IS, SIR, AS A
UNITED STATES SENATOR AND I
WORKED FOR ONE THAT WOULD BE THE
LATE JOHN HINES, YOU HAVE TO DO
THIS DEBATING THE OPPOSITION
THING ALL THE TIME.
I'M JUST CURIOUS AS TO WHAT YOUR
REASONING IS FOR NOT DOING THAT?
>> I JUST -- I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT -- IT'S ACTUALLY A FACT
THAT FOX NEWS AND PART OF SEAN
HANNITY IS A PART OF HAS SPENT
THE LAST FIVE OR SIX WEEKS
UNLOADING ON US AND SAYING
OUTRAGEOUS THINGS AND GOING
AFTER US IN A WAY THAT MORE SO
THAN ANY OTHER -- THE OTHER
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES COMBINED.
SO THIS IS NOT A FAIR AND
SERIOUS VENUE.
I JUST WOULD NOT TAKE THAT --
IT'S AN UNSERIOUS INVITATION
BECAUSE HE'S ALL IN FOR DR. OZ.
THAT'S THE TRUTH.
>> Sean: HERE WITH REACTION,
LARRY ELDER WITH CLAY TRAVIS.
LARRY, LET ME START WITH YOU.
THE THING HE DOESN'T WANT TO DO
IS ANSWER A QUESTION.
HE'S NOT BEEN ASKED A LOT OF
HARD QUESTIONS.
HERE IN PENNSYLVANIA, 81 BILLION
INDUSTRY, HE WANTS A MORATORIUM
ON FRACKING.
HE WANTS ABSOLUTELY NO
RESTRICTIONS ON ABORTION.
HE WANTS THE TAXPAYERS TO FUND
HEROIN INJECTION SITES THAT ARE
SAFE.
THIS GUY HAS ADVOCATED FOR MORE
CONVICTED MURDERERS TO BE
RELEASED THAN ANY OTHER
CANDIDATE IN THE HISTORY OF
RUNNING FOR THE U.S. SENATE.
HE WANTS TO OPEN THE PRISONS IN
PENNSYLVANIA AND LET OUT A THIRD
OF THE POPULATION.
THIS GUY IS MORE LEFT THAN
BERNIE SANDERS ON EVERY ISSUE,
LARRY.
NO WONDER HE WON'T COME ON THIS
PROGRAM OR ANSWER ANYBODY'S
QUESTIONS.
>> YEAH.
IT'S INTERESTING, SEAN.
HE SAYS YOU'RE ALL IN FOR
DR. OZ.
FOR CRYIN OUT LOUD, I RAN FOR
GOVERNOR IN CALIFORNIA.
THE NEWSPAPERS WERE ALL IN ON MY
OPPONENT, GAVIN NEWSOME.
THE L.A. TIMES.
I STILL DID INTERVIEWS.
IF WE REPUBLICANS DON'T DO
INTERVIEWS BECAUSE THE MEDIA IS
ALL IN ON THE OTHER SIDE, WE
WOULDN'T DO ANY INTERVIEWS.
REGARDING WARNOCK'S VIDEOTAPE,
THAT IS COMPELLING STUFF.
YOU KNOW THERE'S A DOUBLE
STANDARD WHEN A FEMALE ACCUSES A
DEMOCRAT THAN A REPUBLICAN.
THE MEDIA HAS A DIFFERENT
ATTITUDE.
REMEMBER TARA REED?
SHE CLAIMED THAT JOE BIDEN
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED HERE.
KAMALA HARRIS SAID SHE BELIEVED
TARA REED.
NOW KAMALA HARRIS WORKS FOR JOE
BIDEN.
NOW SHE'S WORKING FOR SOMEBODY
SHE ACCUSED OF A SEXUAL ASSAULT
OR SHE BELIEVES TARA REED IS A
LIAR.
WE INTERVIEWED WHAT YOU KNEE
THAT BRODRICK THAT SAID THAT
BILL CLINTON RAPED HER AND
HILLARY CLINTON VERBALLY
INTIMIDATED HER.
HILLARY HAS NEVER BEEN ASKED
ABOUT WHAT JUANITA BRODRICK
SAID.
THE DOUBLE STANDARDS ARE ALL IN
YOUR FACE.
>> CLAY, LET'S GO TO RAPHAEL
WARNOCK FOR A SECOND.
YOU SAW THIS TAPE OF HIS EX-WIFE
ALLEGING THAT HE WAS USING HIS
CAR AS A WEAPON TO RUN HER OVER
AND IN FACT RAN OVER HER FOOT.
HE'S BEEN TAKEN TO COURT FOR NOT
PAYING CHILD SUPPORT.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT HE OBSTRUCTED
JUSTICE, HE WAS ARRESTED FOR
OBSTRUCTING JUSTICE IN A CHILD
ABUSE INVESTIGATION FOR A CAMP
THAT HE WAS RUNNING AND THAT
ULTIMATELY FOUND FIVE EXAMPLES
OF CHILD ABUSE.
NOW, WHY ISN'T THE MEDIA IN THE
GREAT STATE OF GEORGIA BEEN
QUESTIONING RAPHAEL WARNOCK THE
WAY THAT THEY'VE BEEN HAMMERING
HERSCHEL WALKER?
>> YOU KNOW AND LARRY KNOWS AND
EVERYBODY OUT THERE LISTENING TO
US KNOWS WHY.
BECAUSE GEORGIA IS THE FIRE WALL
NOW, SEAN.
WHAT YOU OFFERED TO JOHN
FETTERMAN, I WOULD EXTEND THE
OFFER THE SAME WAY -- MAYBE HE
WON'T CLAIM THAT I'VE BEEN A
CRITIC OF HIS, BUT I'D LIKE TO
THINK THAT I HAVE.
HE'S THE WORST CANDIDATE THAT
EITHER PARTY HAS NOMINATED FOR A
STATE ELECTED OFFICE IN ALL OF
2022.
THAT WAS BEFORE HE DIDN'T HAVE
THE HEALTH STATUS TO BE A UNITED
STATES SENATOR.
THE JOB OF A SENATOR IS TO
ARTICULATE IN A CONVINCING
MANNER AND ADVOCATE FOR YOUR
STATE.
HE CANNOT DO THAT.
HE CANNOT SPEAK.
HE HAS TO CONDUCT INTERVIEWS
USING A DESK TOP COMPUTER SCREEN
IN ORDER TO SEE WHAT'S BEING
ASKED.
IF YOU WATCHED THAT NBC
INTERVIEW, HE WASN'T CONSISTENT
IN BEING ABLE TO ANSWER THOSE
QUESTIONS.
SO IF YOU LOOK AT THESE NUMBERS,
DR. OZ IS GOING TO WIN IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
I THINK WHAT IS GOING ON AND
I'LL SAY TO THE PEOPLE OF
PENNSYLVANIA AND CERTAINLY THE
PEOPLE OF GEORGIA, JUST LISTEN
TO THIS CASE.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT JOE BIDEN
HAS DONE A GOOD JOB AS
PRESIDENT?
IF YOU DO, THEN YOU SHOULD VOTE
FOR RAPHAEL WARNOCK NO MATTER
WHAT.
HE IS A RUBBER STAMP FOR JOE
BIDEN.
IF YOU HOWEVER BELIEVE AS MOST
GEORGIANS DO AND MOST
PENNSYLVANIANS AND MOST
AMERICANS DO THAT JOE BIDEN HAS
BEEN AN AWFUL PRESIDENT, THEN
HOW IN THE WORLD COULD YOU VOTE
FOR SOMEBODY TO BE A RUBBER
STAMP FOR HIM?
HERSCHEL NEEDS TO WIN.
IT'S A BIG DEAL.
WE'RE 27 DAYS OUT.
THE PEOPLE OF GEORGIA HAVE A
CHANCE TO REDO THE ERROR THAT
THEY MADE IN JANUARY OF 2021
WHEN THEY PUT RAPHAEL WARNOCK IN
OFFICE.
HE NEEDS TO BE GONE.
JOHN FETTERMAN QUITE SIMPLY
CANNOT DO THE JOB.
IF HE HAD ANY SENSE OF DECENCY,
SEAN, HE WOULD STEP DOWN AND
ALLOW SOMEONE ELSE TO RUN.
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T HAVE THE
HEALTH ABILITY TO DO THIS.
THESE ARE MASSIVE ELECTIONS.
>> Sean: HE'S THE MOST RADICAL
CANDIDATE TO RUN IN THE COUNTRY.
LARRY, I DIDN'T MENTION THAT HE
WANTS PENNSYLVANIA TO BE A
SANCTUARY STATE.
AS MAYOR OF BRADDOCK
PENNSYLVANIA, HE CHASED AN
INNOCENT JOGGER DOWN THE STREET,
HELD HIM TO A SHOTGUN TO HIS
FACE.
NOTHING HAPPENED IN THE TOWN TO
JUSTIFY THAT.
IMAGINE IF A TRUMP DID THAT OR
ANY REPUBLICAN HAD DONE THAT.
>> THEY'VE GOT TWO ISSUES.
THEIR ISSUE IS ABORTION AND BY
THE WAY THESE REPUBLICANS OVER
THERE ARE SYSTEMIC RACIST.
THEY HAVE THAT AND THAT'S IT.
THEY CAN'T TALK ABOUT PRICES,
THEY CAN'T TALK ABOUT GAS
PRICES, THEY CAN'T TALK ABOUT
THE BORDER OR THE PULL-OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN.
ALL THEY CAN DO IS POUND THE
TABLE ABOUT ABORTION AND CALLING
THE PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT
SYSTEMICALLY RACIST.
THAT'S ALL THEY GOT.
COME NOVEMBER, THEY WILL BE
TOAST IN THE HOUSE AND HOPEFULLY